there is a push to ban the sales of dogs
cats and pigs at clark county pet stores
it comes as our local shelters are just
overwhelmed with an influx of animals
coming in victoria saha in studio
joining us with what this could mean for
shelters and for pet stores brian the
big push here is to encourage people to
adopt not shop this proposal was just a
discussion today at the county
commissioners meeting but those on both
sides are hoping they will be heard
when you come across a cute little puppy
at the pet store it's hard to not fall
in love
but then you have animals at the shelter
whose eyes show they're also in need of
some love and affection we do have a pet
overpopulation issue that's been really
exacerbated by some of the economic
issues that we've seen the animal
foundation currently has more than 800
animals
ceo hillary gray is on board with clark
county's new proposal to ban the sell of
dogs cats and pigs at stores she hopes
it will encourage more people to be open
minded about the animals available at
the shelter as those cute puppies you
see at the store could be surrendered
when they aren't so little anymore it's
an idea whose time has come and really
socializing our community to the fact
that there are pets that are in need but
those whose livelihood depend on the
sales of puppies say they aren't doing
anything wrong i would love for us to
sit down run the numbers let's see if
these animals that are at animal
foundation local rescues are part of our
animals or are we the problem we went to
a few stores that sold puppies prices
were starting at 2 000 dollars for them
whereas the animal foundation gets
animals of all different sizes and
breeds for just an adoption fee and
sometimes those are waived
there weren't any decisions made in
today's meeting the next step would be
to do a business impact study denise